it was 1 000 one of my favorite things
to film literally just because of the
people that were all on set
today we are here to witness the
greatest sequel
since empire strikes back as barry
and iris renew their vows and lend new
meaning to the term
relationship goals jordan
the flash season seven finale just aired
and something that i have wanted and
have been championing for for the
longest time finally happened
barry and iris officially renewed their
wedding vows
how did it feel to be a part of it oh my
god okay so
i mean you're watching the scene and if
and if you're if you're a camera that's
rotating around the room it is
everyone that you love in this show
every single character that you love so
so deeply maybe aside from a couple of
people that are coming to mind right now
but like
most of the characters that you love are
all in this one
space in in in in the in the west house
and it just feels it's like it's the
cookout it's family dinner it's
thanksgiving it's that
with all these people and we're
celebrating you know obviously mom and
dad
um we're doing their vows and it's such
a sweet moment we get to go into flash
time and there's a really sweet intimate
moment between
anderson grant that's so lovely and
on top of that i bart has a little
surprise for mom and dad
mom dad this is for you
and sings a really really sweet song
for their vowel renewal that was
actually written
by an artist for that artist's best
friend's wedding
so it's like the most it's
it's it's a moment of affection and
nurture and love and
calm and care that is so so so
justified in this moment uh and in the
season
and and i think that i mean it's one of
it was 1 000
one of my favorite things to film
literally just because of the people
that were all on set
i'll give you all the affection
just grab a warm body and pick up
the key if you need somebody
somebody like me what was the vibe like
on set that day
wonderful it was everybody it was the
whole if you looked at the call sheet
you're like
we're all here it's all these people
that you grow to love
so deeply all there to celebrate two
people so the love that everyone has is
incredible these are all
in terms of the characters in terms of
us as people as actors as friends
a lot of laughs that day so as you can
imagine kind of hard to keep the day
going because
everyone has bits and everyone's keeping
everyone's laughing and making other
people laugh
and people are singing and you know it
was
such such a great time carlos was there
and whenever he's
around and on set everything's just it's
it's just great everyone was so great
it's awesome i have nothing bad to say
and i promise today
to continue loving you with my whole
heart
it was beautiful luck following that
yeah
we had the lovely jessica parker kennedy
on for almost a full season
of the flash timeline
afflictions out of the question would
you be interested
in coming back in season eight for a
longer arc for bart
oh i'm i would be super interested in
making any kind of impulse return at all
um
i love the character uh i've i've become
rather obsessed with
bart um as just i mean as a character
just in general like as a hero yeah but
just bart
as a character just him as a person yeah
love so much i have fun if i'm playing
with my fun expo
because i feel like the most me i think
he's a little more hyper he's a little
more
you know all over the place with that
electricity surging through him i think
it's okay that he's a bit high
probably probably i i don't function
that way i'm a little i move a little
slower i'm a little more laid back just
in general and in life
you know definitely a leader and i've
run a business in a company and
everything like it's all
that's all fine and dandy but i'm not
like you know bouncing off walls and
things like bar does but that
is fun i get to do that on set in a
superhero costume
like life's good
it's it's good yo this place is crash
you